Richard people want to know what does
your morning routine look like I wake up
really early every day and I play tennis
with somebody who's a lot younger and a
lot fitter than me and we play singles
and you know we give it everything we
can and you know end up you know
sweating big-time and having a lot of
fun at this ad you know as well and then
if the wind is up you know go for a kite
surf you know kiting you know a lovely
way just to get it get away from you
know the mobile phones and and and just
get you know get out on the sea and and
then you know after that you know come
back having to have a you know have a
sort of nice healthy breakfast generally
sometimes you know sometimes the not so
healthy found your kryptonite and then
I'm ready for the day thank you so much
for watching I'd love to know what you
thought about Richards morning routine
what your morning routine looks like
what you may have learned from it and if
you want me to continue this series
leave a comment below let me know what
you think thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe I will see
you soon